hey guys today it is the 5th of April my
name is Jeff and you're watching games
but you semester are having another e3
event this year but this time around
it'll be open to the public and feature
playable demos the event will take place
on June 12 and is set to feature a
showcase of upcoming bethesda games this
year there will also be a sort of
after-party called Abbey III Plus which
will feature game demos hosted
interviews and mystery band and most
importantly food if you find yourself in
LA around that time you can register for
a chance to attend the event on the
festus website if not the whole thing is
being streamed so you won't miss out
alleged God of War for concept art has
leaked cluing a center what could be in
store for the next installment yesterday
industry insiders shinobi who has leaked
accurate game info in the past tweeted
across the Rainbow Bridge to the halls
of Valhalla my boy hashtag god of war
for blood leaks followed up and found a
website belonging to former Sony Santa
Monica artist finian mclonergan section
on the site features artwork that
appears to depict Kratos with his iconic
red tattoos in various Norse mythology
inspired environments sporting a new
beard
Sony has not officially announced a new
god of war and these images may be
unrelated that all Kratos is gearing up
to kill his way through the North
Pantheon one or the other the 3.5 ps4
update is so damn close to being out and
Sony have released a video to highlight
some of the new features the update
which is codenamed Musashi will be out
tomorrow and is set to allow you to
appear offline play games remotely from
your PC or Mac and improve on social
feature you will also be able to choose
to be notified when your friends come
online scheduled gaming sessions with
your friends in the event
tab join games more easily by performing
parties and check the PlayStation
Network together put the full details on
the 3.5 update you can check out our
story on GameSpot let me know down in
that comment section what you're excited
for in the new PlayStation update and
hit the game start we've got news on
uncharted 4 and the division update that
is everything I have for you today but
let me know what mattered to you and I
will see you again tomorrow